hello good morning and good afternoon
my name is sam and i am a global product
manager here at kyogen
in today's webinar i wanted to talk
about improved dna amplification
techniques
for using downstream analysis such as
next-gen sequencing microarrays and pcr
in today's webinar we're going to focus
on using improved dna amplification
with our newly released replica advanced
dna single cell kits to use these
the dna that we amplify from a select
number of cells
for human karyo mapping in order to
phase single cell
gene defects
i need to remind everyone before we get
further into our presentation that the
collagen products shown here are
intended for molecular biology
applications
these products are not intended for the
diagnosis prevention or treatment of a
disease
for up-to-date licensing information and
product specific disclaimers
feel free to look at the collagen kit
handbooks or the user manuals
these kit handbooks and user manuals are
available at kyoto.com
they can be requested from college and
technical services or from your local
distributor
so in today's webinar we're going to
focus on the
process of amplifying limited amounts of
genomic dna from eukaryotic cells
in order to do karyo mapping karyo
mapping is often done
when we have couples with a family
history of a genetic disorder
and they want to know whether or not
they're going to have a child
that could have a genetic disorder that
either they are carriers for
or that they have in their family
material mapping this is often used for
pre
pre-implementation genetic diagnosis
such as orpgd
of single gene disorders
down here in this bottom slide
we have an example of what karyo mapping
is looking for
with cario mapping often we look at
snips across
both the mother father and a reference
sample
in order to look at whether or not the
embryo
or the pre-implemented pre
pre-implemented
uh embryo is going to have a genetic
disorder
so with carrier mapping we do
genome-wide snip analysis of the parents
in the close relative
typically we're analyzing anywhere from
300 000 or more snips
and this mostly applies to a very
limited number of cells
which means that we need to have the
ability to have enough
dna to go through and use these methods
this representative haplochart is
showing you the father mother and
several embryos
and you can see the makeup of the
genetic material in the different
embryos
and you can see that we can have allelic
representation from either of one
or more of the fathers and mother's
chromosomes
one of the issues with cario mapping is
that we are performing this on a limited
number of cells
so we need to collect the cells and we
need to be able to
amplify that genomic dna in order to use
our analysis methods
when we're looking at the amount of dna
that we're starting with it's often a
limited
couple of picograms and for doing this
analysis we may have to get up to
nanograms or even a microgram depending
on the technique that we're using
whole genome amplification can be used
to overcome this limitation
and really the final data that we get
for material mapping analysis
is really dependent on the performance
of the whole genome amplification
as this is essential to the quality of
the data
you can imagine that as we go through
and we talk about these really important
applications
we need to have kits that allow us to go
through and to
definitely amplify the dna make enough
of the dna
and then to amplify it faithfully so we
don't introduce any abnormal
changes
one of the reasons why we launched our
refugee advanced dna single cell kit
is to tackle these issues and what i
want to present to you
is some of the i behind how we built
this kit
the refugee advanced dna single cell kit
works with our existing technologies
that we built into our refugee product
line
namely our mda or multiple displacement
amplification
the way the mda works is it's an
isothermal
reaction that takes place at typically
around 30 degrees celsius
um this slide goes through the basic
mechanism
of how the mda reaction will work first
we denature the genomic dna
and then primers which are often
randomers are going to bind to the dna
to allow us to prime the 529 polymerase
to start the amplification as the
primers are extended at 30 degrees the
polymerase moves along the genomic dna
or if we're starting with rna we can
make a cdna copy
displacing the complementary strand
which then becomes the template itself
in contrast to other amplification
methods like pcr
our mda does not require different
temperatures
and in the end this results in very long
fragments with low
mutation rates the 529 polymerase that
we use at kaijen has about 1 000 folds
more fidelity than most of the
polymerases that are used for pcr
amplification
and the fragments that we can get can be
very long anywhere from two to seventy
kilobases with these very low mutation
rates
so the product of this mda amplification
can be fragmented for short read
sequencing
it can be used directly for pcr analysis
or it can also be used
for long read sequencing
hydrogen has a number of replica
amplification kits
and when we started to look addressing
the need around cario mapping
as well as several other single cell
applications
we decided to move in a different
direction and improve one of our
existing kits
so we looked at our refugee single cell
kit
and we decided to make some improvements
and enhancements
on it when talking to customers of
course they were looking for improved
quality
so what we are looking for is
reproducible performance
meaning that when we start with a sample
we get enough
and a reproducible amount of product
that comes out of this
we're looking for high uniformity of
amplification
and minimal technical bias and this is
basically measured by having
no allelic dropout
customers are always looking for shorter
workflows so we simplify this down to a
single tube workflow with only a couple
of different
pipe heading steps so the protocol that
we're going to talk about
is currently a lot faster than our our
refugee
dna single cell kit and it's easy to
handle
meaning that there's only a few steps
that you have to do in order to get your
product
and it has a very flexible workflow one
of the things that we've incorporated
into our refugee advanced
kit is a single cell storage buffer
this means that you can collect the
cells that you're using
put them in in our cryo preservative
buffer freeze them away
and then pull the cells out when you
want to process them all at one time
this sample storage buffer allows cells
to be collected and shipped without
having an impact on the cell quality
it also also preserves the quality of
the cell which preserves the
genomic dna within the nucleus keeping
the genomic dna from being
nicked or damaged which greatly helps
with preserving the quality of the data
and minimizing allelic dropout
so our refugee advanced dna single cell
kit
is an improved version of our refugee
single cell kit
this kit has been optimized for
eukaryotic cells
and the way that we're able to achieve
higher quality
meaning higher uniformity and lower
technical bias
is by implementing our storage buffer
our isothermal
lysis that we use and improve
composition of our reaction mixes
with a much faster protocol the mda
reaction not only takes two hours versus
the six or eight hours we used to use
we've currently launched three different
kits we have a 24 reaction kit
and a 96 reaction kit within these
reaction kits we have the
single cell crowd protect buffer as well
as all the reagents
and then we off also offer the replica
single cell crowd protect buffer as
another
standalone product for researchers that
will be collecting cells
storing them and maybe shipping them to
another facility to do the amplification
and material mapping
this slide shows us the workflow for a
collection and amplification of a
cell from the beginning to the final
refugee reaction we collect the cell in
four
microliters of our replica advanced
storage buffer
we add three microliters of our
denaturization solution
and then we allow that to sit around for
10 minutes at room temperature
following the lysis and denaturization
of the genomic dna we add
three microliters of the stop solution
we mix
and then we add our refugee advanced
single cell master mix
which contains the polymerase and the
amplification reaction
we allow this to go for two hours at 30
degrees celsius
stops the reaction at 65 degrees for
three minutes
and then at the end of this we have our
amplified dna
from a single cell we typically get 25
to 35
micrograms of our amplified genomic dna
from start to finish there's only um two
times that we have to open our tube in
order to add reagents
and the total time is 2 hours and 20
minutes with only 10 minutes of hands-on
time
one of the metrics that researchers are
always interested in when they
look at amplifying genomic dna is the
consistency of the results
here i'm showing you the results of
collecting
single cells using one of our single
cell collection
tools called the kaya scout we collected
cells from the gercat
lobo mcf7 hela cell lines
we collected several different cells
here that you can see for the number of
single cells analyzed
we did this over a couple of different
experiments with different operators
you can see here that the average yield
when starting with a single cell was
anywhere from 25
up to almost 40 micrograms of dna
with a very low coefficient of variation
reagent lot over here
refers to different reagents or a lot
sizes of our
pre-advanced dna kits showing you that
as we manufacture different lots
we get consistent yield and elites
enough yield
to go through and do microarray and ngs
analysis
we also went through and used genomic
dna as a standard
so here we see a similar experiment
where we have several different
technicians going through and starting
with one nanogram of genomic dna
different lots of our refugee advance
kits you can see the mean yield that we
get here
is somewhere between 35 to 45
micrograms of amplified genomic dna
this next slide shows the uniformity of
using the refugee advanced dna single
cell kit and in these instances we're
starting with
single cells that were isolated using a
single cell collection
device and we're comparing here our
repuge
advanced which is our new kit versus our
traditional
replica original kits with the um
single cells for the refugee advance the
cells were collected and put into the
cryo-preservative buffer
with the replica original they were
collected and put into
pbs and then processed according to the
protocol of each of those kits
the genomic dna was used as a standard
and our downstream analysis of the
amplified genomic dna
is a targeted kiac targeted dna panel
this panel has about 200 240 different
genes and covers about 850 kilobases
you can see here what we're looking at
is the uniformity
or the percentages of the bases with a
certain percentage or within a certain
thinning of the mean read length
using 40 nanograms of genomic dna or 40
nanograms of the
amplified material we've
looked at the binning of five percent
mean relay
greater than 10 percent 20 percent and
greater than 30 percent of the mean read
depth
here you can see that the
replic advanced dna single cell kit
shown in blue performs
better than our traditional refugee dna
kit
when looking at the amplified bases and
the uniformity across the ngs
assay
another way to look at this is the gini
coefficient
the gini coefficient allows us to look
at the uniformity
the smaller the gini coefficient the
more uniform the amplification is of a
single sample
so here we're looking at the uh in the
light blue
a new replica um advanced single cell
dna kit
in the dark blue our our um
classical refugee kit and in red here
we're looking at the genomic dna
and you can see here the lower gini
coefficient associated with the replica
advanced kit
showing higher uniformity across the
samples that were processed
we also compared a multiple displacement
amplification
uh technique versus other techniques
such as picoplex and malbec
here we're looking at the percent
uniformity across five percent
ten twenty percent and thirty percent of
the mean re-depth
and we can see here that in the um dark
blue
is the genomic dna control in light blue
we have the
replica advance kit in the
red we have the picoplex and in the
grayish we have the results from the
mallback
we used the same kiac targeted dna panel
that covers 850
kilobases and we used each of the
protocols
as they are laid out in the handbook
starting with these single cells we can
see that the
replica advanced dna single cell kit has
higher uniformity and we can see this
also when we go through and look at the
gini coefficient
which is showing us the uniformity
across the individual samples
in conclusion the new replica single
cell kit shows higher uniformity
than other sources technologies for
amplifying genomic dna
in this experiment we're looking at the
allelic dropout
the way that we've looked at the allelic
dropout is to
use the genomic dna as a reference and
we're looking at
single allelic dropout of heterozygous
snips
we defined the loci with a frequency of
a snip allele between 25 to
75 percent as heterozygous and what we
went through
is we analyzed the number of
heterozygous snakes
in genomic dna and whether or not they
turn to
homozygous nix after whole genome
amplification
a change from a heterozygous to a
homozygous nip
would be an indication of allelic
dropout
on the y-axis here we're looking at the
percentage of heterozygous
nips with single allelic dropout the
genomic dna being the reference
has of course no allele drop out with
the
replica advanced we can see we have
somewhere between about 15
to 30 percent of the oil dropout with
the picoplex and the malbec
technologies for amplifying the dna you
can see we have much
higher allelic dropout so in conclusion
the refugee advanced dna single cell
kits
show a lower allele dropout rate than
other sorts of technologies
and we attribute this to a couple of
different factors the first factor is
the preservation of the cell
in the cryoprotect buffer which protects
the genomic dna
the second is the isothermal lysis that
we have
and the third is the multiple
displacement amplification with the 529
polymerase
all of these things added up together
lead to lower
allelic dropouts
we looked at several different
applications and what i'm going to show
you is some data for carrier mapping
that was done
in collaboration with milosev hornak at
repromeda biology park in the czech
republic
in this experiment biopsies which
contain a few cells were isolated from
the trophy epiderm of embryos
using a fine needle glass needle and
they were transferred into pcr
tubes so the workflow is to take the
biopsy
the biopsied cells which are a few cells
are washed three times in droplets of
the cryo-protective buffer
and 0.1 percent pvp the 0.1 percent pvp
is to keep the cells from adhering to
the pcr tubes
they are then after the wash preserve
put into one microliter of the cbp with
0.1 percent pvp
and then it is 20 degrees
following the storage the process by
adding 3 microliters of the pure
cbp they are then subjected to
the whole genome amplification using the
replica advanced dna single cell kit
and then their karyo map using the human
curio map 12 dna analysis kit
which is a microarray platform from
aluminum
through this study there were 10
different
cases that were analyzed and i'll show
you a data from a couple of these cases
with these 10 different cases you can
see the number of samples that were used
the code for these is the te are
trophoectoderm samples er embryos
and ivf are the number of times that
in vitro fertilization was was used in
the
study the disease that was looked at is
shown here as well as the gene
or the genetic defect
that we're looking for in the um study
across these ten different samples um
this process was used
they were analyzed on the aluminum
microarray
and one of the nice things of the
microarray platform
is that it will give you some sort of qc
metrics of the whole genome amplifica
amplified dna
the selective qc metrics that are used
to judge
whether or not the dna has been
amplified
faithfully is the overall call rate of
85 to 99 percent
the av rate of 20 to 30 percent allelic
dropout rate is zero to 80 percent
a missed call rate of less than 5
so what we have done here is a table of
the 10 different experiments that were
done
in this table we have the father's
mothers the embryo and e and
r would be the reference sample if there
was a reference sample
we're looking at the call right here so
in order for
these samples to be further analyzed the
call rate needs to be
above 85 percent and if you look across
a call right here of experiment one
case two h3 four five etcetera
you can see the call rates are all very
high at close to
ninety four to ninety nine percent
the a b rate should be twenty to 30
percent you can see the av
rate is all within the um standard
specifications
and the allelic dropout rate should be
less than 80
and you can see that the allele dropout
rate here is at most
around five percent in case number one
missed call rates also are very good at
uh zero percent
uh for all of the cases that were
studied with the
qc metrics showing very good
qualifications
these samples were further processed and
looked at downstream into case studies
first case study we'll go through is
called
case study one fragile x syndrome this
is a case where
a child of 12 year or 12 months old
showed delayed development and mild
mental retardation
the child was tested for the praetor
william angelon syndromes and they
came back negative and then a test for
fragile x syndrome revealed 266
cggn repeats which is the full mutation
spectrum
for this particular disease
when doing um cario mapping of the
mother
the mother showed 111 cgg and repeats
which is the pre-mutation spectrum
without a phenotype
if the couple decided to have any future
children
this premutation spectrum could convert
over to a beautiful mutation
on spectrum and there's a big risk here
of that occurring again
so in the second pregnancy that this
couple wanted to have they wanted to
avoid the risk for fragile x syndrome
by using pre-implementation genetic
diagnosis
so eight separate embryos were developed
and down here we're looking at the
haplomap
of the different um embryos
you have the mothers haplomap there's
two alleles m1 and
m2 if a haplotype is linked with the
mutation it's going to show up with the
star here so the m1 has a star the m2
does not
and then for the father since this is
x-linked the father has one x chromosome
one y chromosome
if he donates an x chromosome it'll be
shown here as a p
if you donate to y it will be shown here
as a zero
in addition to also getting the haploid
type around fmr1 other chromosomal
abnormalities can
also be discovered by going through and
looking at the data
in the end two embryos were identified
one male one female which had the m2
haplotype
with either the father's x or y
chromosome
without any additional chromosomal
abnormalities
and one of these was chosen for in vitro
fertilization and pre and implementation
back
into the mother for a second child
the second case study we have is
nephrophintesis in this
particular case study a couple with one
healthy child
decided to go through and have
ivf in virtual fertilization and
implementation because they were unable
to have
a second child the fetus showed
polysystonic kidneys under regular
ultrasound
check dna testing
the fetus fetus from amniocytes showed
that there was a homozygous mutation in
the t-mem-67 gene
which is the causative gene for kidney
polycytosis and
nephrosynthesis
and so going back and looking at the
haplomap of the mother and father
it showed that the mother and father are
healthy carriers of the mutations in the
heterozygous state
so the couple decided to perform another
round of ivf
using pgd and cario mapping
so down here we can see that there were
nine different creoles
the haploid type here of the mother and
father are shown since this is no longer
an x-linked
um abnormality
you can see that there's two different
alleles for the father
p1 and p2 the haplotype that is linked
to the mutation is going to be shown
here as a star
and it's highlighted here in blue so out
of these nine different embryos we had
one here that had the blue which would
not be used for
further implementation so out of these
nine we had eight
left and then when looking at other
source of chromosomal abnormalities
there was one that are detected
so this allows the couple to go through
and
to pick a good embryo for implementation
that would allow it to not have the
t-mem 67
mutation and they selected one that was
did not have a mutation in either of the
alleles
so in conclusion the refugee advanced
dna single cell kits are highly
suitable for human karyo mapping they
provide reliable and reproducible
results for phasing and haplotyping
of single gene defects in addition to
using these with microarrays we've also
used the same kits for
next-gen sequencing analysis using
low-pass sequencing
as well as pcr interrogation of specific
mutations
and when using karyol mapping for pgd
this helps avoid the risk of severe
genetic disorders from
inherited parents with a known family
history of genetic disorders
and also detects chromosomal antibodies
if present in the embryo
so in addition to be able to look at
particular types of mutations or
particular types of haplomas
we can also see chromosomal number
abnormalities
with that i'd like to thank you for your
attention and coming to today's
presentation
today we talked about the refugee
advanced dna single cell kits
which are available from kyogen if
you're interested
in um or you have any questions feel
free to walk
to reach out to kyogen by emailing kaya
webinars at kyogen.com
or feel free to contact kayajin um at
this email address
or at this our website down here again
i'd like to thank you for your time and
have a good day